[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV
78 dans l'actualité de ce mardi 5
septembre la rentrée scolaire se
poursuit toute la semaine dans les
Yvelines cette année le retour à l'école
se fait sous le signe de l'olympisme à
l'approche des JO de Paris 2024 hier des
élèves des écoles Louis Pergaud de
trappes et du collège La couldre de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux se sont réunis au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans en Yvelines
site des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques digitruck c'est le nom de
ce camion itinérant qui s'est installé à
Noisy-le-Roi jusqu'au 9 septembre à bord
on peut y apprendre par exemple à
détecter les fake news ou comprendre
comment rédiger un CV en ligne et des
ateliers gratuits proposés pour
favoriser l'inclusion des personnes
parfois éloignées des nouvelles
technologies une expo à voir jusqu'au 17
septembre au château de Maisons-Laffitte
magie baroque entre réalité et
envoûtement partez à la rencontre de
deux grandes magiciennes célèbres de la
Renaissance dans le reste de l'actualité
on parle également du château de
Maisons-Laffitte concernée par le
sixième loto du patrimoine et puis
l'invité du 7 8 en musique du 7 au 10
septembre les Old Factory festival
revient pour une cinquième édition sur
l'île au monde à Mantes-la-Jolie au menu
Keziah Jones Ben l'Oncle Soul ou encore
Danakil ce qu'il faut savoir avec Arnaud
Bel membre du comité de programmation de
l'événement
les Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
c'est 32 sports qui se dérouleront dans
des sites d'exception des élèves à
l'écoute et particulièrement
enthousiastes ce lundi 4 septembre jour
de rentrée scolaire marquent également
le début d'une année olympique nous
avons souhaité marquer l'événement dans
les Yvelines en réunissant donc des
élèves d'élementaires et des élèves de
collège sur un site exceptionnel puisque
nous sommes au Vélodrome de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et ce vélo
Drôme c'est un site olympique pour
l'occasion un flambeau olympique a été
dévoilé il fera le tour des écoles
yvelinoises et à chaque arrêt ce sera
l'occasion de faire découvrir de
nouvelles activités autour du sport
en deuxième partie de journée les élèves
de primaires ont visité l'ensemble du
vélo de Rome national et ont reçu les
conseils des collégiens pour conduire un
vélo en toute sécurité un moment de
partage et de transmission là on est en
train de leur faire des tours de vélo
sur une sorte de circuit pour les
apprendre comment faire du vélo et
respecter les panneaux j'aime plus aimer
le moment même ici comment dire là
comment on fait du vélo là j'ai bien
aimé des casques ont été remis à tous
les élèves participants de quoi bien
démarrer l'année
ancienne député des Yvelines aujourd'hui
ministre des Solidarités et des familles
Aurore Berger a choisi la PMI le Centre
de Protection Maternelle et Infantile de
Rambouillet pour sa première visite
officielle dans le département elle a pu
rencontrer les professionnels du secteur
et échanger sur leur quotidien parce que
tu es intéressant c'est surtout
d'entendre les professionnels parler de
leur métier la manière avec laquelle ils
ont évolué tu fais qu'on est aussi
conscient que c'est peut-être plus
difficile d'être parents aujourd'hui ça
l'était il y a 20 ans ou 30 ans parce
qu'il y avait pas les mêmes risques on a
beaucoup parlé de la question des écrans
comment on fait pour expliquer aux
parents les risques évidemment qui
peuvent y être associés sans être
culpabilisant aussi pour les parents ou
enfantillants mais on a besoin un moment
de prévenir de ces risques pour faire en
sorte que le développement de l'enfance
passe dans les meilleures conditions
possibles pourquoi mon bébé pleure-t-il
pourquoi est-Il constipé ou encore quels
aliments puis-je lui donner autant de
questions que les jeunes parents peuvent
se poser à la naissance alors du Centre
de Protection Maternelle Infantile de
Rambouillet les professionnels de santé
sont à votre disposition pour répondre à
vos attentes l'année dernière 700
enfants ont été accompagnés à
Rambouillet ainsi que 600 enfants grâce
au bus itinéraire les difficultés qu'on
rencontre au quotidien sont aussi les
difficultés que l'on peut rencontrer
avec des parents l'éloignement des
professionnels de psychiatrie ou
psychologues lorsque Luna vend des
parents en difficulté on n'a pas de
chiffres exacts mais effectivement on
constate de manière un petit peu
empirisme une augmentation du nombre de
maman qui sont en difficulté
psychologique sur notre territoire et
d'ici 2030 la ministre souhaite
l'ouverture de 200 000 places d'accueil
de haute qualité
[Musique]
les ronds bleus et gris allez-y tirez-le
découvrir les bases du smartphone le
thème de l'atelier dispensé ce jour-là
dans le digitrock à une dizaine de
participants jusqu'au 9 septembre
prochain un camion bien particulier fait
étape devant la gare de Noisy-le-Roi
reconverti en salle de classe connectée
ce lieu propose des cours gratuits pour
mieux comprendre les équipements
digitaux un univers parfois obscur pour
ce public senior les questions les plus
classiques c'est par exemple pourquoi
j'ai ça à quoi ça me sert sur mon
téléphone voilà bon bah comment ça
marche le bluetooth le mode avion il
sert à quoi qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
QR code Reader
QR code lecteur
Girard 82 ans n'avait jamais eu de
formation sur les nouvelles technologies
il se réjou de recevoir des cours
structurées pour mieux intégrer des
informations parfois complexes j'avais
d'énormes lacunes sur le numérique il y
avait beaucoup de fonctions du
smartphone qui est un bijou
technicité beaucoup de
particularités du smartphone que
j'ignorais totalement donc j'ai appris
il m'en reste encore beaucoup beaucoup à
apprendre mieux appréhender
l'utilisation d'un ordinateur protéger
ses données ou aider à la recherche
d'emploi en ligne le public est invité à
découvrir les fondamentaux quel que soit
son âge la fracture numérique peut
concerner toutes les générations les
jeunes ils ont super doué en fait à
utiliser le smartphone etc mais par
contre dans ce qui est de basique
comment configurer qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire attention la sécurité etc et là
ils ont besoin vraiment venir et
travailler de 100 personnes sont
attendues sur ces 15 jours de présence à
Noisy-le-Roi organisé depuis 2021 le
digitrock a accueilli 4500 apprenants
dans toute la France ils poursuivra son
itinéraire numérique aux Essarts-le-Roi
dès le 11 septembre
dans le reste de l'actualité yvelinoise
un nouveau site du département retenu
pour la sixième édition du Loto du
patrimoine il s'agit des cavenors du
parc du château de Maisons-Laffitte
construite au 17e siècle par
l'architecte François Mansart elles sont
dans un état de grande vétusté une
restauration a déjà été lancée l'an
passé l'objectif à terme y maintenir une
activité hippique et ouvrir le lieu au
public après les Restos du coeur c'est
au tour de la Croix-Rouge française de
tirer la sonnette d'alarme l'association
fait face à des difficultés financières
un déficit de 50 millions d'euros en
raison de la hausse des coûts et des
demandes d'aide plus 7% de demandes au
premier semestre de cette année dans les
Yvelines la Croix-Rouge dispose de 16
unités locales 11 épiceries sociales et
d'un camion itinérant qui sillonne le
territoire à la rencontre des
bénéficiaires de son côté le
gouvernement indique avoir mobilisé 156
millions d'euros pour l'aide alimentaire
cette année
l'hommage à Michel Hidalgo à
Clairefontaine ce matin le nouveau
complexe du nom de l'ancien
sélectionneur des Bleus décédés en 2020
a été inauguré au Centre national du
football pour l'occasion Didier
Deschamps sélectionneur de l'équipe de
France Thierry Henry entraîneur des
espoirs et l'ex footballeur gentigana
était présent et aussi Valérie Pécresse
Présidente de la Région Île-de-France la
collectivité a soutenu ce projet à
hauteur d'un virgule 3 millions d'euros
pour la création de 40 chambres avec
vestiaires de différents espaces et de
deux terrains synthétiques
[Musique]
jusqu'au 17 septembre plongée dans les
sous-sols du château de maison à
Maisons-Laffitte et venez découvrir la
nouvelle exposition magie baroque
[Musique]
à travers des décors merveilleux partez
à la rencontre de deux grandes
magiciennes de la Renaissance Altina et
Armide il y a d'abord alchina qui est
une création d'un auteur de la
Renaissance qui s'appelait larriost et
qui à travers le Roland Furieux qu'un
immense roman chevaleresque a inventé
cette figure d'une magicienne qui vit
sur une île lointaine et qui va piéger
des chevaliers dans son jardin et son
palais d'illusion et va tomber amoureuse
de l'un d'eux qui sera Roland la
deuxième magicienne évoquée dans cette
exposition est Armide une figure
inventée par le poète le Tasse à travers
son roman la Jérusalem délivrée c'est de
femmes ont inspiré de nombreuses
créations artistiques au 16e et 17e
siècle jusqu'à Louis XIV qui a souhaité
représenter alfina dans une grande pièce
théâtrale pour inaugurer son château à
Versailles
nous avons par ailleurs dans le tout au
long de l'exposition travailler avec
deux danseurs périnalisa et
Jean-Baptiste plumeau et ces deux
personnages représentent à la fois le
chevalier en prisonné et la magicienne
donc nous apportons aussi un peu
d'humanité dans ces décors donc on suit
l'histoire en quelque sorte on emmène le
visiteurs à travers l'île enchanté tout
d'abord une création de Laetitia Miral
et on terminera par un tableau qui est
celui de la métamorphose ou le chevalier
qui a été emprisonné figé en quelque
sorte dans cette ILLUSION va se libérer
bien entendu de ces charmes filtres
d'amour jardin enchanté banquier les
oeuvres prennent vie grâce aux ambiances
sonores et visuelles mises en place
attention à ne pas vous faire ensorceler
ou envoûté
demain mercredi toujours pas de nuages
mais de la chaleur à l'horizon dans la
matinée les températures seront déjà
égales ou supérieurs au 20 degrés dans
le département l'après-midi il va faire
encore très chaud jusqu'à 33 degrés dans
les secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie de
Rambouillet à Versailles fera 31 degrés
32 degrés du côté de Houdan et ce
mercredi 6 septembre nous fêterons les
Bertrand tout de suite l'invité du 7 8
présenté par Mathilde Franco
[Musique]
du jeudi 7 au dimanche 10 septembre
c'est le retour de Léon Factory festival
sur l'île aux mots à Mantes-la-Jolie au
programme une vingtaine de concerts sur
trois scènes différentes pour en parler
avec nous Arnaud bel bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes membre du comité de
programmation de ce festival première
question pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas les olfactory festival en un mot
c'est quoi en un mot en un mot ça sera
du vent le festival pourquoi du vent
parce qu'on s'intéresse particulièrement
aux instruments avance sur ce festival
c'est vraiment la marque de fabrique
puisqu'on est sur un territoire le
Mantois ou depuis le 19e siècle il y a
énormément de facteurs d'instruments
donc de fabricants d'instruments avant
et dont Selmer lui fait crampon qui ont
une renommée mondiale mais totale c'est
les plus grandes marques mondiales de
ces instruments avant c'est fabriqué ici
on vous la mettre ça en avant d'autant
plus qu'il y a énormément d'accessoires
risques de fabrique de fabricants pardon
de hanche de tous l'écosystème autour de
des instruments à vent qui se top aussi
entre ici la Normandie proche La
Couture-Boussey etc et on a on a
vraiment un triangle entre ici Évreux et
La Couture-Boussey vraiment sur les
instruments avant et c'est ça qu'on met
en avant sur ce festival du Mantes
festival du dieu du vent donc
effectivement fait un petit clin d'oeil
à à ça et qui fait aussi la tipisme du
festival puisque on ne s'inscrit pas
dans un festival de jazz ou d'un
festival de musique actuelle ou de
musique classique on s'inscrit vraiment
dans une lignée d'instrumentistes donc
on est sur tous les styles on est on
commencera plutôt vers les musiques
classiques vous le verrez le samedi pour
finir vraiment sur de l'afro groove à la
fin donc tous les styles de musique sont
un peu balayés c'est vraiment un
festival pour les curieux et un
festivals de fête pour tout le monde on
essaie de d'initier tout le monde à
cette à la pluralité de la musique ce
qui est aussi quelque chose qui
correspond pas mal à
nos besoins actuelle on est beaucoup
moins lié à un style de musique on
s'intéresse de plus en plus à différents
styles de musique à différents
interprètes et ça nous permet aussi de
croiser des chemins différents
d'artistes qui s'intéressent autant à
l'électro comme musique classique et
comment on fait le lien et ben c'est
viaol Factory on en est très content
alors on va parler un petit peu de la
programmation notamment des têtes
d'affiches Ben l'Oncle Soul va fouler la
scène de sur l'île aux Moines pour les
al Factory festival ce sera dimanche ce
sera dimanche pour son son grand retour
alors avec avec des cuivres évidemment
avec des instruments avant qui vont
l'accompagner sur son répertoire qui est
maintenant très soul blues alors il
était très soul chanson au départ de sa
carrière tout le monde connaît ses
énormes tubes mais maintenant il a une
vraie il a développé une vraie facilité
un vrai répertoire autour de saule et de
du blues c'est vraiment je pense que
c'est l'apogée de de sa carrière
actuellement il faut vraiment venir voir
Ben L'Oncle au sol le dimanche d'autant
plus qu'il est bien accompagné et à
quelle heure il sera vers les 18h
quelque chose comme ça en fin
d'après-midi on a voulu vraiment faire
de cette journée du dimanche une journée
familiale c'est une tradition aérol
Factory on commence par des spectacles
pour enfants et puis ensuite avec on est
sur des concerts qui peuvent qui peuvent
autant contenter les parents que les
enfants il y a vraiment du lien à ce
moment-là et on a eu des très très
belles éditions avec des très très
belles rencontres parents enfants devant
des artistes ça crée vraiment une
atmosphère très particulière et bien
justement je vous propose d'écouter un
petit extrait et puis on va continuer de
parler de la programmation juste après
[Musique]
c'était la
alors autre tête d'affiche Arnaud bel
c'est Danakil le groupe de reggae il
sera sur scène aussi dimanche il sera
sur scène dimanche alors il y a
différents groupes et il y a deux scènes
trois scènes qui jouent en alternance
sur le site du festival mais là ça sera
la même scène que Ben L'Oncle au sol
pour finir le festival avec Danakil qui
a un groupe qui a toute une histoire
avec le territoire puisqu'ils sont
originaire des Yvelines et depuis ils
sont connus mondialement avec un reggae
très très particulier très qui est leur
marque de fabrique qui était vraiment un
concert très très festif et très attendu
dans le coin venez participer à cette
grande fête et alors du reggae on passe
au blues je dirais puisque samedi vous
accueillez Keziah Jones qui est non
seulement blues mais aussi l'inventeur
du bluff funk donc d'un mélange entre le
blues la funk et les musiques du monde
puisque lui aussi a des origines
africaines et on est vraiment sur sur un
artiste qui a vraiment marqué son époque
donc à partir de du de la fin du 20e
siècle jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant c'est
vraiment un répertoire hors norme que
tout le monde connaît et là il viendra
peut-être nous faire une petite surprise
aussi dans le cadre du festival en
justement jouant le jeu de la rencontre
avec d'autres artistes d'accord et pour
terminer sur sur les grandes têtes
d'affiches il y a vos doigts qui sera
aussi le samedi qui fête les 10 ans de
sa carrière disons après le méga tube
qui je suis pas content vous avez dû
longtemps et vous l'avez en tête rien
que la façon dont je le dis ça vous le
met en tête c'est vraiment un groupe
très festif sur scène avoir en famille
aussi pour cette soirée qui donc
commencera par des musiques classiques
et finira comme je le disais tout à
l'heure vraiment par un côté afro funk
très marqué là aussi je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait et on revient tout
de suite après
[Musique]
je ne vois plus ça
je ne peux plus ça
alors ça c'était pour les têtes
d'affiches Arnaud belle qu'elles sont
les autres artistes un peu moins connus
qui vont quand même jouer durant ce
festival un peu moins connu ou connu par
plutôt une niche de personnes mais qui
méritent d'être des montrer au grand
public comme le concert de chapelier fou
par exemple Chapelier Fou et un artiste
qui vient de l'électro mais qui a été
formé dans différents conservatoires
dans la dans la région messine puisqu'il
est originaire de là-bas et qui vient
avec un projet qui mêle ses compositions
issues de son répertoire électro avec un
septet de musique classique et là on est
vraiment à la croisée des chemins entre
différentes musiques vraiment ce qu'on a
envie de montrer et il jouera en
ouverture de la grande scène le samedi
du festival et après il y a également
des artistes le plus d'obédience
cubaines comme mon parole qu'on connaît
bien sur le territoire puisque mon
parole est aussi un professeur au CRD de
Mantes mais qui a aussi une carrière de
musiciens assez incroyable
au niveau national au niveau
international il jouait avec tous les
plus grands et là il vient avec un
projet autour de Dizzy Gillespie on
sauce cubaine à un moment à voir aussi
dans le temps du festival alors vendredi
vous installez également une fan une fan
zone pour les fans de rugby puisque
c'est l'ouverture le match d'ouverture
de la Coupe du monde de rugby c'est vrai
qu'on va passer deux jours avant le
temps fort du festival qui sera le
samedi dimanche avec des concerts
payants mais aussi des concerts offerts
on va passer deux jours totalement
offert le jeudi et le vendredi avec un
écran géant de 60 mm carré donc on est
vraiment sur un très très grand écran
alors pour effectivement montrer le
match de rugby que tout le monde attend
puisque c'est le premier match de la
Coupe du Monde enfin je vous refais pas
tout l'histoire France Nouvelle-Zélande
on mettra évidemment notre ADN du
festival tout autour de cette fan zone
puisqu'il y aura des produits locaux en
vente sur sur le bar des bières locales
des des produits de restauration aussi
avec des artisans locaux et il y aura
aussi des exemple qui vont jouer avant
après sur différents endroits du
festival donc très très bonne ambiance
sur cette fan zone et la veille on sera
plutôt dans dans l'espace puisqu'on aura
la chance d'avoir le film 16 lever de
soleil 16 lever de soleil c'est le
nombre de levées de soleil que vous
voyez Thomas Pesquet quand il était tout
là-haut et il y a le film qui va être
montré en direct du temps des musiciens
donc son compositeurs qui ont le
paierait qui va venir en quartet jouer
sur ce film là c'est aussi un très très
bon moment les le ciel est avec nous on
passera un bon moment sous les étoiles à
ce moment-là ça vous tenait à cœur
d'ouvrir le festival bah aux fans de
rugby mais aussi aux fans de cinéma oui
oui ça nous tient à cœur d'être plus
gris disciplinaire aussi sur ce temps du
festival on est certes très musical
puisque c'est l'ADN du festival on
s'ouvre à différents champs et puis les
rencontres entre différentes c'est
plutôt pas mal d'ailleurs le jeudi il y
aura aussi une exposition sur Thomas
Pesquet il y aura il y aura pas mal de
choses on fait vraiment des liens entre
entre les différents arts sur ce temps
du festival et ça vous tenait aussi à
coeur que du coup il y a deux jours sur
quatre du festival qui soit entièrement
gratuit en accès libre entièrement
gratuit parce qu'on a encore alors c'est
un festival qui se développe énormément
et qui touche un public mal en très
large mais on a encore des capacités
d'accueil et on a envie d'en faire
profiter le plus grand nombre donc c'est
vrai que ça ça nous permet d'ouvrir à
différents types de publics et de
montrer que le territoire est vivant et
les produits du territoire sont
sympathiques et qu'on peut passer un
moment de mieux vivre ensemble qui est
qui est fort à well Factory festivalaire
ça fait partie un peu de l'ADN du
festival les produits locaux le côté
éco-responsable zéro plastique quand
vous essayez en tout cas c'est une
marque de fabrique dès le début du
festival l'autrice sélectif évidemment
mais on va beaucoup plus loin avec zéro
plastique pas de bouteille d'eau pas de
des produits locaux on va aller chercher
il y a au bar le choix qu'avec des
produits qui sont fabriqués sur le
territoire et qui sont qui sont de
grande qualité donc
c'est vrai que ce développement sur le
temps du festival est très important
parce qu'on a aussi eu
un côté où on peut montrer que un autre
une autre façon de faire et possible et
c'est vraiment dans l'ADN de ce qu'on a
envie de développer alors l'année
dernière vous avez réalisé près de 5000
entrées c'était un record cette année
vous espérez le dépasser ce record on
espère bien le dépasser oui on espère
bien le dépasser on est déjà on a
rajouté une quatrième journée sur ce
temps du festival et puis c'est vrai que
les réservations vont bon train alors il
reste des places sur tous les surtout
les concerts mais par contre c'est vrai
que ça réserve beaucoup et donc on est
très content du retour public et puis le
temps est plutôt avec nous donc on
espère vraiment encore battre ce record
de fréquentation d'un festival qui a été
créé juste avant le covid qui a eu la
force de se maintenir malgré les aléas
et de s'adapter et maintenant c'est vrai
qu'on voit que le le retour du public
par rapport à tout ce qu'on fait et
vraiment très positif donc venez passer
faire partie de la fête cette année du 7
au 10 septembre merci beaucoup Arnaud
bel d'avoir répondu à nos questions
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 invité je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]